to each of you take turns with your
project one person will be the
implementer one person will be the idea
person and then vice versa once the door
wants the thinker and then you take
turns we both have a lot of ideas i
usually get ideas during industry like
when people are lecturing and I'm not
taking out some what they're saying I'm
writing down a she'll Bible or something
but um we develop our ideas together and
would you say oh yeah i think if we do
go back and forth you'll have an idea
i'll have an idea will develop it
together and then you sort of forget
whose idea was or you come to think that
it was your i feel like i sometimes do
and then i need to be corrected as I
should be haha and yeah so we just sort
of trade off and you know sometimes all
direct or sometimes she'll direct and
sometimes will just produce an act and
it really depends on so many different
factors what project is actually next
that we don't even know anymore but like
you've never done whatever sort of
majesty you know like we ended up
working at the book last year instead of
sort of working on a new film project
and we wanted to start a new film
project but then we felt like this
Kickstarter was a good opportunity to
you know give her this little baby that
we six year old babies were pushing out
on that house give it a proper sort of
send off before I put in the world
you